hi everyone its Johanna here this is a
requested video and I think it's a
really important topic to speak about on
binge eating some of us might be going
through this right now and it's actually
sabotaging our workout plan and we want
to be able to stop binge eating and so I
hope this video will be able to help you
out so what is binge eating binge eating
is characterized as a compulsive
overeating in which you consume huge
amounts of food within a short period of
time when you're binging
you are out of control it's a vicious
cycle you feel depressed and it's just
an angry and so you pinch and then you
feel even more depressed anxious and
angry about binging and so you binge
again so what are the causes of binge
eating the two most common causes are
number one driven by emotion you feel
anxious angry upset and you choose to
use food to suppress your emotions
instead of dealing with it
another reason can be that you are
currently on a starvation diet or you
have previously been on an extreme diet
the issues I have with extreme diets is
that they do not teach lifestyle changes
which can be maintained over the years
hence when you deprive your body from
the nutrition and food your body needs
eventually your body will repel and
overcompensate with the first binge the
binging starts irregularly but over time
it will become more frequent and it will
become a habit according to research 3.5
percent of US women suffer from binge
eating and that is more than double the
amount of bulimia and more than four
times of anorexia binge eating happens
regularly at least twice a week over a
period of six months so ask yourself
these questions number one do you feel
out of control or unable to stop when
you're eating - do you think about food
all the time 3 do you force yourself to
eat even when you're full and
SiC afterwards for do you stock up food
and eat secretly five do you eat excape
your worries stress or to come for
yourself six
do you eat continuously throughout the
day without any set meal times 7 do you
feel disgusted guilty and ashamed of
yourself after eating and finally are
you desperate to take control of your
weight and your eating habits if your
answers I guess to most of these
questions let's take a look at how we
can stop sabotaging our workout plan
with unhealthy binge eating here are my
top ten tips tip number one is to keep
binge at bay so instead of depriving
yourself from your cravings and
indulging to the entire bar of chocolate
over weekends why not have small
portions of these few times a week so
instead of eating directly from the
chocolate bar break them into small
pieces have a couple of small blocks and
stall the rest away this way you are
more in control of your food portion and
you are enjoying your food instead of
feeling guilty afterwards the second tip
is to set yourself a timer wait when you
have the urge to binge stop set yourself
a 15 minutes timer and think do you
actually feel hungry or are you actually
feeling upset stress which make you want
to stuff yourself with all the chocolate
bars if you're feeling upset take the
time to think what's going on or is it
just boredom if it's your emotions then
let's not numb ourselves with food but
take the courage to do with your
emotions don't hide your emotions speak
to someone speak to your friends or your
families we women tend to binge on our
own
instead I want you to pick up the phone
call someone that you're close to your
friends or your family members and share
your emotions I'm sure they will
time to listen to your problems and to
give you some positive advice to make
you feel good or you can even speak to a
professional that will be able to help
you out to do with your issues so stop
using food as your comfort but instead
speak to someone because this will be a
long-term success in avoiding binge
eating on the other hand if you find
yourself going through the fridge
looking for something to eat but you are
not sure what to eat you are most likely
experiencing boredom cravings grab
yourself a glass of water drink your
water and walk away or find another
distraction do whatever you need to do
to get your mind off the craving go out
for a walk go for a job do it an
activity you enjoy my favorite is just
to take the time to relax and clear your
mind listen to some calming music
meditate and just even go for a nap when
you wake up you will feel so much better
and you will not be binge eating so try
that out just listen to calming music
and go for a nap trust me you will feel
better another of my favorite method is
to chew on gums if you really have to
put something into your mouth because of
your cravings or because you're stressed
out chew gums this will reduce your
craving and it will also help you to
reduce your stress level and to calm you
down so if you have to chew gums quite
often in a day I would say try it out
and do it and you will really calm you
down and reduce your cravings the next
step is to record your intelligences
even if you've just eaten an entire
chocolate bar is not too late to do
something about it write down what
triggers you to binge so that you can
overcome it in the
future stop take a step back reflect and
learn to take control of the situation
instead of allowing your emotions and
your food to take control so start
writing down your indulgences the next
tip is something I've always emphasized
on whether you want to lose weight to
maintain your weight or to stop binge
eating which is to start your day right
by having your breakfast research has
shown that those who do not pack their
breakfast are more prone to binge eating
and to have higher calorie meals
throughout the day so start your day
right by having a breakfast you can
watch some of my videos for really quick
and simple breakfast ideas they do not
have to be complicated at all and tip
number eight is please do not ever go on
a restricted diet ever again you have
tried them and they have been proven not
to work in fact you might have even put
on more weight before you started
dieting start educating yourself with
healthy eating look for healthy and
delicious recipes and enjoy your
cravings in moderation this will not
only help you to lose weight but I
guarantee you you will be able to
sustain it for life and my next tip is
to start getting active plan an exercise
program which you will want to maintain
this can be either working out with my
workout videos or join a dance club stay
active does not only make you feel young
look your best it will also keep you
happy and energized but do not punish
yourself in the gym after a binge stick
to your regular workout routine maybe
you can go for an extra walk but avoid
the mindset of working off the calories
you consume this too can lead to an
unhealthy cycle of binge eating and over
exercising so the key here is to do with
a core issue of your binging instead of
working the calories off because it will
not help in long-term and finally learn
to love and forgive yourself stop
beating yourself up over it you did not
stop binging overnight
will not be able to stop that quickly
either every step you take away from
binge eating will make you feel better
about yourself it will take months or
even years to completely change your
habits but start to love yourself for
who you are and not what you look like
just like any other addictions binging
develops into a habit in order to break
this cycle
stop picking up new positive habits and
focus on them the key to success is to
try and try and try again and you will
get there for new fitness food and
motivational videos please like share
and subscribe to my You Tube channel and
website do follow me on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter to stay connected
with me thanks guys
you